[Musique]
jaloux
on est les seuls à faire un jingle en
silence et bien c'est cosy comme ça
c'est très intime qu ambiance bien aller
- jean-luc on va rappeler le principe
parce que ce sont les derniers de
l'année c'est vrai que c'est une des
séquences qu'on vous préférez dans
l'émission jean luc voit tout vous le
savez il voit ce qui se passe en
coulisses on voit ce qui se passe même
pendant l'émission quand moi je ne vois
rien et jean-luc vous dévoile tout de
cette émission
aujourd'hui c'est une spéciale 4/3 ça va
être fou c'est que de l'île et dire que
l'inédit et setca tiers pub free série
il ya plus de free il ya plus de pub
donc c'était une des deux autres katia
fallait trouver d'autres idées et tout
de suite une question c'est la dernière
de l'année
c'est parti bonjour je m'appelle thierry
je voulais vous dire je regarde presque
tous les soirs parce que maintenant j'ai
un peu de temps en fin d'après-midi pour
regarder la télévision et je vous adore
voilà j'ai pas vraiment question à vous
poser je voulais juste vous dire une
blague
vous savez pourquoi les habitants du
japon ils veulent tous devenir cheval
est bien parce qu'ils sont des japonais
alors alors il ya personne pour me dire
tu sors
alors
isabelle darbellay il y voit la titille
hidhab bon jean luc tu as les réponses
il n'y a pas de questions metalcore une
virée pour voir je vais réponse mais
vous voulez tout de suite des réponses
ou non c'est quoi on va faire les
réponses de jean luc lemoine dans un
instant non mais moi en tout cas merci
thierry pour ce moment de rire et
surtout d'avoir accepté de lancer les
dernières quatre tiers de la saison car
il assure il l'a dit ce sont les
dernières 4/3 est donc temps de faire un
petit bilan as
car si dans l'ensemble l'année a été
assez calme sirem passé deux trois
petites choses sur lesquelles je vais
revenir ce soir
déjà il ya eu pas mal de nouveaux dans
l'équipe avec chacun une utilité
différentes
géraldine maillet par exemple on l'a
recruté pour son côté un peu vulgaire un
no limit en exclusivité les isoler la
plus grosse insultes de jardin' de la
saison elle parlait de cyril je préviens
ça fait mal qu'après le jury a demandé
jeudi voilà quatre est ce que vous êtes
choqué par ça et le bandit
quel bandit d'emballage 1 din avec club
handi elle est clairement c'est ça
compatibles dans le même genre on a
recruté aussi maxime gainey a oui à
cette année et benjamin castaldi
ces deux façons de voir la vie pour vous
compreniez bien je vous montre une
situation vous allez voir comment ça
réagit d'un côté ou de l'autre
aïe aïe aïe mais comme moi ça va alain
cotta
ce qu'il fallait
g
et chaude à sanaa
et c'est un bandit c'est un bandit
d'aborder un brigand voilà en tout cas
un petit point lexical nous avons appris
ce soir que selon la personne chipie
égale [ __ ] maxime de vous l'avez vu
un qui a très vite trouvé sa place dans
l'équipe
grâce à son expertise média et ses tongs
tuation car oui si vous voulez peut-être
pas toujours remarqué mais maxime vient
ponctuer chaque séquence par un petit
mot frappé au coin du bon sens par
exemple si je dis là bas je sais pas
roger l'adage pourrait bien mon fils et
trois hamburgers lui dans son pré veut
dire en gros appétit exactement c'est
exactement ça va être ça je vais fait
petite compil j'adore ça
balla gaye topo bon benjamin fayote
sélection sur twitter est ce que benzema
n'aurait pas dû être en équipe de france
voilà le dit barret se poserait question
est d'accord c'est une bonne visite mans
series et l'usagé non merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
rang 6
c'est à la mode ou chine capitale de la
mongolie où l'on bat or vient de ma tort
exemple phare le frère dalle
si elle m'a frôlé alors je ne réformerai
pour plus de moi
[Musique]
et là les mecs là là là les gars ça fait
super étrange en plein milieu de vos
ébats
il crie un autre prénom que le vôtre
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ces cas
parce que ça peut arriver avec lui vous
me connaissez bien mal géré un deal à
proposer vas-y je vais gagner
messieurs 1
[Musique]
on tient un nouveau truc avec sa mort
c'est montréal ça ça ça va revenir
ces questions je suis fan on est exquis
mon ami aussi lorsqu'il vient avec
maxime sait qui est tellement sauf qu'à
côté de lui dans l'équipe on a
l'impression que tout monde et punk
alors les a expliqués dans la dalle et
katia pour le plus grand bonheur des
abeilles morini-bosc maxime et noir y
est pour remettre dans le droit chemin
ses camarades ses brebis égarées là vous
allez voir il va faire passer un message
à vaduz valérie qui n'en peut plus et
qui va leur envoyer promener
vous ne rêvez pas valérie va dire fuck
non scellées c'est la transformation de
la saison
[Musique]
les rebelles 30 secondes de la sirène
elle l'a fait quand même merci maxime
talbot à votre service saad tué moi
c'est votre chronique en vise à rendre
service parfait maxime vous savez comme
je vous aime vraiment je suis fan de ce
gars là c'est réciproque
si tu aime beaucoup un jour tu finiras
par faire du saut à l'élastique allez
comme je vous montre tout ce soir je
voulais faire aussi comment la
différence trentaine et hors antenne ça
c'est important
alors je joue revenir sur un passage de
l'émission pendant un moment on a refait
dans l'émission des face à face à vous
connaissez le principe même il se
rappelle plus c'est lui qui voulait il
se rappelle plus c'est quoi ça c'est
simple un sujet polémique
les chroniqueurs doivent dire s'ils sont
contre ou pour ans passant d'un côté ou
de l'autre de la table et comme ya passé
deux chaises
il ya toujours un ou deux joueurs qui
restent debout 1 derrière à faire
potiche
le pire c'est quand cyril lancé le face
à face juste avant la pub fin du temps
il y avait de la pub
quand on s'invente un chauffeur
je pars faire un geste bien si on n'est
pas du vol c'est trop bien déjà 5
millions 5,1 des études et donc c'est
vrai donc s'excitent pas citoyens à
venir
j'ai une indication je voulais c'est
parler après j'aurai une indication à
vous donner on embrasse mathieu tu fais
des bisous le sens des professeurs on
sait quand ça tourne mal et y est ce que
vous voulez qu'on passe un petit objet
nantes alors ça c'est notre passion
alors c'est un taux médian cxl en plus
ce soir 2009 * line à 12 non maintenant
alors ça c'est ça je sais que vous
adorez a lâché mme rigal toujours même
principe se plaint de séquences courtes
il provoque un maximum de jeunes
merci monsieur merci c'est réciproque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un lait c'est leur merci les
chéris c'est ma chanson préférée
ma vie entière ça c'est intéressant
vraiment si peur
[Musique]
attention 3 2 1 j'ai ma première ligne
[Rires]
[Musique]
je sais pas
michel là dessus puis ça a l'air d'être
un mec propres quand j'ai un petit
l'assaut mais ce n'est sa mort si jeune
[Musique]
mais enfin non si vous
l'heure aussi
[Musique]
merci en tout cas et c'est pour ça que
je vous aime autour de la table et
d'ailleurs on donnera des nouvelles de
la saison prochaine en tout cas et c'est
pour ça que je vous aime autour de la
table et d'ailleurs avec de la saison
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est marrant j'ai vu le jour vous avez
perdu une dent c'est pas du tout ça
j'aimerais manger du riz gones c'est un
chewing gum et je l'avais collet et en
enlevant le kurde en baisse à enlever
toute la matière mais je vous jure c'est
vrai un mythe mais tu te fais mal non
plus bontemps voir les images si tu veux
on va pas les rois repérer la chine n'en
voit pas la jeunesse par isabey
attention ça repart c'est très brave
[Applaudissements]
sasasmit corse et un petit apéro qui
nous a rejoint bonsoir à gaga jessie
aussi qu'elle ait qui sera avec nous
l'an prochain et maxime ghenim charte
hector je suis bien accompagner votre
cette dernière franchement on peut pas
mérité mieux
mais les musicales du chien moi je moi
je n'en peux plus je voulais donner des
trucs à picorer parce que là on arrive à
un moment un peu délicat à savoir mais
comme j'ai promis la transparence je
suis obligé de dire la vérité
tant pis pour les conséquences alors
franchement je ne sais pas comment
introduire cet extrait ça se passait
pendant une prestation de shakira
[Musique]
voilà faut je libère ma conscience j'ai
absolument rien compris à ce que me
disait benjamin
j'ai souri pour m'en débarrasser le pire
c'est que depuis j'ai regardé 54 x
l'extrait je sais toujours pas ce qu'il
a dit je crois que benjamin petit
problème même si à une diction parfaite
on ne comprend pas toujours mais
personne n'ose le dire parce que ça le
vexin wayside et est alors ce qu'on lui
dise alors on sourit bref et comme carl
et caroline ithurbide je les fais pas
dans son regard
on sent qu'elle veut lui faire répéter
finalement d'y aller c'est pas grave mon
grand
[Applaudissements]
c'est magique les folles je suis pas je
vais vous le dire vous savez pas qui
fument éléments mais c'est vrai que ça
et souvent malheureusement avec mais bon
on aime bien garder son charme
franchement c'est votre charme tout est
volé votre que tu votes tu dis que je
suis vraiment un homme parfait wave ou
prou vautier tu vois que vous m
bon je vous rassure ça n'arrive pas qu'à
benjamin ce genre de mésaventure est
belle aussi pas marrant genre je vais le
voir
géraldine 4 strictement rien ça se voit
à peine maxwell vous a proposé le
provincial mais non mais enfin qu'il ya
de bien c'est toujours une histoire dé
l'isère ça arrive tous les jours avec
qu'ils habitent j'adore alors comment on
fait une rétrospective de d2 où on a nos
petits codes tous les deux c'est gênant
je rappelle qu'elle a envie de vomir
depuis tout à l'heure
soit les länder où je poste une amie a
laissé jean luc est non non non non
j'assiste à un grand moment donc je fais
du ray alors comment on fait une
rétrospective je vais aussi revenir sur
capucine capucine qui a eu du mal à
suivre par moment et qui nous a fait pas
mal de révélations importantes hausses
assez lequoy enfants là bas
[Rires]
ici la belle passe alors par exemple
dans une démarche assez clair d'écrire
sa légende nous avouer seize années
qu'il lui arrivait de pt dans son
sommeil un oui mais par contre quand ses
camarades essayer de trouver des
synonymes plus élégant que p outre août
là elle est perdue vous allez vous en
rendre compte qu'on valérie benaïm
faisait une blague sur le move en a
avant avant avant avant valérie benaïm
café benjamin castaldi dans la loge
[Applaudissements]
mais à qui il a mis en avant non
concernant benjamin s'est pas de ces
gens là qu'on parle et d'ailleurs il est
temps de faire un petit focus sur le
râleur de l'équipe celui que tout à
gassin permanence je ne pouvais là une
soirée difficile mais oui je saute ça
non mais je sais très bien de quoi il
s'agit et c'est pas grave ça très grave
et je voudrais surtout rendre hommage ce
soir a plus fait qu' on était assis à
côté de lui cette année
pour mieux comprendre je vous propose de
revivre juste unis condamnent
excusez-moi mares pour thierry l'une des
missions de la vie du roi
et là c'est une émission aux prises au
hasard c'est une émission présentera une
seule d'accord c'est même pas une copine
c'est juste sur une émission et des
missions du roi delà des colorations
capillaires
[Musique]
faire un petit vent froid arrête
de 50 ans parce que les laboratoires
jean yanne
le
motif
candidate importateurs pour de tels
georges tarif famille change
ils aideront de la matinale
je
manger
[Applaudissements]
d'abord la meilleure place et c'est vrai
qu'à mais il est très drôle mais j'ai
quand même envie d'aller bouffer lui et
ça va si longtemps j'étais vous je
mangerai with équilibré je peux me
permettre
bravo à la passion un plaisir fou à pas
son nouvel airbus
je ne vois pas besoin de le dire je suis
pas faire un débat sur ça va faire un
face à face à l'étonnant si ça peut vous
arriver éventuellement les uns et les
autres je ne sais pas besoin d'aller
dire à votre voisin
je viens de péter alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que et je le dis
souvent connaissez vieil adage paix
avouée à moitié pardonnée
là il y en avait il ya au moins cinq ou
six bah oui ben voilà alors c'est vrai
et je rappelle bien sûr si vous êtes
avec quelqu'un qui a des flatulences
n'oubliez jamais ce vieil adage
également premier senteurs premier pékin
et qui ont régi où sa famille la famille
à la lourdeur en région c'est la
dernière ils se lâchent ils se font
plaisir
oui lâche tout merci beinheim pour finir
sur benjamin plutôt long de l'année de
vocabulaire des chroniqueurs s'est
enrichi de nouveaux mots comme d'art
carats sera uni comme ou qu on se
souvient notamment de tirer moreau qui
avait fait sensation avec son
utilisation de normal ah oui dormal
balle titi est plus là ouais mais à
benji qui sent fort on compte fait des
enfants de stars de mots comme dirait
camille crois que titi moreau a une
aventure avec olivier de chez carglass
résultats de fumer régulièrement le
commissaire maigret dans la série du
même nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa cavale satar moi je pouvais pas faire
cette rétrospective sans parler d'un
maillon essentiel de l'émission le
sniper priapique aa
j'en ai peur pris appui c'est comme ça
dans le dico oui dans le petit robert
est comme ça on le sait tous assure
michel et est un séducteur hors pair
est-ce qu'on ignore sait d'où il vient
son inspiration
cette fuite est toujours le trouver le
mot juste pour séduire les femmes eh ben
j'ai trouvé retrouvé esseulé pour
essayer de les soins à maxime car ça
concerne pas super g ici qui lui plaît
beaucoup
ah parce que pendant que maxime faisait
des grandes phrases des tours de magie
pour éblouir à la nouvelle chroniqueuse
alors mais chez lui il allait à
l'essentiel en écrivant des mots simples
une ardoise non exclusivité voici
comment ce génie à trouver ses mots
n'ont fait rentrer malvy tu melvin mai
fabien maîtresses
je m'attendais et votre dos il s'inspire
de rené la taupe c'est bien non ça n'a
eu jean-michel qui a aussi beaucoup
donné cette année au niveau physique
1 on se rappelle notamment du jour où il
avait dû danser torse nu et les trois
mousquetaires qui je rappelle ont un
abonnement dans la même salle de sport
que lui pas de bol ce jour mis son
basset démagnétisée jeu trahir un secret
jean michel a été assez déçu par cyril
ce soir là non si si jeanine et du
manque de reconnaissance de sa
performance
un ami et van der garde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais
vim
c'est à dire mais je comprends qu'il
soit déçu parce qu'elle n'ait pas eu un
mot pour lui je suis bien sûr cette
année jean michel a fait tout ce qu'il a
pu pour s'attirer les faveurs du patron
ah oui alors je vais vous dire la vérité
au départ je voulais décerner un titre
au chroniqueur le plus les bottes de la
saison le fayot d'or mais moi j'ai pas
pu parce que cette année on a un fayot
de platine voit que lui
[Musique]
vous savez nos chanteurs recevoir les
programmes en à ce que les mathieu j'ai
dit ce que je vous dis merci je côtoie
dans ce pv juste après j'ai peur
mais ça c'est dix ans
le citoyen candidat john la première
réponse c'est camille combal
elle est là qu'est ce qu'ils sont qui
est votre chroniqueur préféré moi
j'allais dire ça non non on est tous ces
enfants 90 jours amende à 99%
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'arrive à faire parler par jerry
perrault plus ouverte aux talents
moi j'aurais eu la voix de garou est ce
que j'en ai fait l imagine avec les
meufs n'y a même pas besoin de te
dépasser
on ne vend plus que vous ne prenez pas
ça fait pas
de rien
changer
[Musique]
ça nous énerve concerne voilà mais bon
je me retiens souvent ah oui à janvier
dans le dire marchera jamais et
franchement à paris c'est un ami voilà
l'ennemi continue pas du tout et il veut
mettre en confiance c'est robert mongeon
mis à nous fasse on vous suit on est
aspiré par votre succès des deux coupes
parlait la beauté le succès ou à l'est
de zenten d'ailleurs sachez juste pour
me donner le moral c'est vrai merci
janvier le bras de mon coach mental que
tu perçois vous n'êtes pas dans la mer
deux frères quoi sauf au coach mental ah
oui c'est vrai c'est beaucoup trop
sexuel quoi merci ainsi les très bons et
très bons l'attention et lagat caroline
ithurbide a bien fait de venir à 23h26
carreau merci d'être là en tout cas j'en
ai chialé bienfaits coach sexuelle a dit
pas ce que j'ai dit pour les joueurs
déjà compris mais je préférais passer à
autre chose bon on l'a dit tout à
l'heure jean michel cette année c'était
surtout beaucoup de vannes sub
équatoriale
si on considère que l'équateur chez
l'homme c'est ce niveau la ceinture la
différence entre un humoriste
traditionnelle et jean-michel c'est
qu'un humoriste se demande si ça valait
bonne et après la 10 alors que
jean-michel c'est contraire il dit ça va
d'après il se demande si elle était
bonne mais pour s'en sortir les truc de
vieux filou là isabelle nous disait que
plus jeune elle avait participé à la
fête de la châtaigne
quand elles étaient comestibles
exactement comme d'habitude vous allez
voir jean-michel va sortir une vanne
très foireuses et comme il sent que ça
passe pas il va faire semblant de
chercher quelque chose sur son téléphone
[Rires]
dis moi non j'ai une soirée and haas
alors à jean patrick les doit passer
parce qu'il a une soirée papa il passera
moi j'ai une seringue lancé je te
rejoins
[Applaudissements]
tu es très bonne pour idra michel on
recevait vincent nick lowe moi je la
trouvais bonne chercher cooper mais
c'est un ami faubel m faut que je mette
en confiance pour l'année prochaine donc
le maintien mais installé vous tous les
2 sera plus rapide
on s'est posé la question soit jeudi
pour un ami ouais c'est vrai il est sale
je vous préviens d'emblée chez lui il ya
du sable
faites attention à ce qu'on est on merci
on en a fait un aller d'autres choses
donc là on est dans les mains de prix de
jean michel et on recevait 20110 clos
qui nous parlait de la table je suis
sera de faire le lancement ou pas sa
résidence et non pas des excuses moi
aujourd'hui j'arrête
non mais fais comme tu veux alors c'est
a dit à faire donc on recevait vincent
duclos voile et de l'attachement de ses
fans je vous demande parce que en fait
c'est la suite qui est surréaliste
j'adore ya toujours des filles en plus
qui attendent devant le studio va y
avait son avis tous donc voilà on est
tranquille non mais c'est moi à chaque
fois ouais ouais mais courageuse elle le
problème c'est qu'à chaque fois je crois
qu'elle vienne pour moi donc elles
viennent d'un mois font ils arrivent à
quelle heure va sans dire
fini que miss monde à part et parce
qu'elle émane
[Applaudissements]
ah bah là ils sont attachés c'est normal
c'est nick lowe nice il table par km
soit ouvrir des portes abbas
en fait chez vous quand on fait une
mauvaise à nos portes à direct à j 1 et
sébastien duclos navy c'est pas méchant
hun sen a dû s'arrêter là le problème
c'est que jean michel cohen vannes il la
répète à tout le monde mais là il va se
tourner vers maxime gainey qui va pas du
tout avant la réaction qu'il attendait
le moment surréaliste du mois ce moment
où jean-michel commence à paniquer quand
quelqu'un trouve vraiment drôle
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'il ait pas me garder la tête et
l'autre qui le chauffe mais vraiment tu
devrais écrire un bouquin sur sa case
donnerait aujourd'hui j'ai lancé une
idée
ouais franchement fait de lens ne
missiles pour les pensions quand même on
aime bien mais l'inquiétant avec kindy
dernière katy redit pot de fin de saison
comme cpu des pots de départ que je
voulais stade et donc j'avais tous mes
camarades au bistrot pente à fraisses on
est passé au ralenti c'est touche pas
mon bistrot
[Musique]
merci pour ce vent cpm elle aime ça avec
nous deux photos sur chaque même si audi
terminus
comment ça s'est passé
technique digne de rêve de rails
le driver de la stib
seul hic la poule elle a vraiment
[Musique]
compris en 2011 tant de temps
dieu
soit vous gagnez et j'avais gagné dont
je gagnais vous il une pénis outre le le
[Musique]
perez n'a pas brillé non plus par ton
coderre monture est accro des terres
n'étaient pas meilleures cette tuerie
non
mais si c'est leur intérêt mais leur
faim premier rendez-vous est quelqu'un
qui connaissait pas avec quelqu'un qu'on
connaît c'est pas un premier rendez vous
quelque chose de rejeter
et puis ça va marcher bah si les règles
sont si new york 2011 même si la réponse
merci qu'on s'en plaignent qu'on le
regrette ou pas la t il on m'attend
c'est beaucoup une question
ap année rapport aux images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas tu ne sais pas si c'est pas
fini il en reste encore et oui c'est une
spéciale soit la dernière
c'est la dernière séquence il tombe
passé pour la dernière fois tout ce
qu'on n'aurait pas voulu voir et
entendre dans l'émission et on commence
par isabelle morini bosc lors de la
journée mondiale de l'environnement
j'ai fait un bilan dans la loge enfin
dans le penthouse de cyril et pour la
déco on avait mis des animaux en peluche
ah oui un conseil si vous voulez paquet
de bugs
ne donnez jamais un lapin en peluche à
isabelle et vous verrez à la fin de la
séquence
j'ai en avant première ces crises et de
nous arriver on va voir des problèmes ah
oui à regarder puisque aurait pas voulu
voir mais entendu l'environnement nous
ça nous parle un être vas-y
[Musique]
chaud chaud chaud chaud
heineken nv de montciel il est le meneur
de jeu 3e et on a un best seller
s'appelle le jus des vainqueurs
amboise en plus quel cadeau c'est à dire
mais si tu commences à me connaître tu
dois noir est-ce qu'on choisissait le
questionnaire avant le fonctionnaire b
questionnaires sont autant de questions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'important c'est de pouvoir réaliser
ses rêves
ouais c'est une heure d amour ou l'a pas
vu ça m'a donné un coup d'arrêt aux ânes
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tous connaissent et
nora seni le minet plus tu peut
sauvegarder tu peux rajouter lui là il
n'est pas mal non
à l'univers la souris reza couilles ici
il est pas mal non dirait jacquouille
plus cool que jacques c'est lui qui va
présenter télématin
il va vous amener avec lui et paola et
non je crois pas mais en revanche c'est
vrai que vraiment on est en train en
garde avec serait on va regarder avec
fred au coeur des mots de au coeur de
moi je te regarde
[Musique]
d'abord j'ai énormément d'affection pour
besoin parce que je le connais depuis
très longtemps on était ensemble sur tf1
absolument parce que quand on s'est
rencontré j'étais enceinte
et donc voilà et lui venait de rentrer
on l'a d'or on est le test moi par
exemple personne manor personnes ont été
jetées sur ce sujet
m
[Musique]
benjamin castaldi parler de télé-réalité
professeurs et ça ils sont mariés ne
faites pas ça chez vous juste vous là il
est là vous avez parlé mal d'un ami amir
qui est un album formidable et j'adore
cette chanson je mène de main pour
m'excuser étonnant mais puisque vous
avez alors je voudrais dire à mr hédi
saidi n'importe quoi j'avais réussi à
toulouges économie j'y connais rien non
c'est juste quand j'ai vu l'affiché avec
le pied non mais pour un présumé pour
rassurer à venir c'est comme quand il
dit b comme beat c'est un truc qui
sortait sais pas quoi dire et amir
l'album verra lire et ils font bien
passé il ya eu un titre i bat janot
ramière savez la chanson on dirait c'est
une de mes préférées dans les sépales
d'ailleurs sait comment la nation
aujourd'hui que vous aller remercier
voudrais remercier
je remercie les jeunes filles et garçons
qui entre avec moi parce que ils sont
restés en alternance au début deborah
qui a fait une grande partie de la
saison en prêt il ya et qui après you
déborah et puis je veux remercier mon
monteur et 10 en dessous si et puis tous
les infographistes qui m'ont maudit
toute l'année parce que j'en connais
beaucoup de travail merci à tous alors
moi je voudrais remercier je sais pas ce
qu'on va passer de cinq à treize et
après on a une surprise pour la fin de
l'émission et même pour le public
aujourd'hui je voudrais remercier parce
que les quatre tiers encore une fois
cette année c'est à un niveau
exceptionnel vraiment on voit encore ce
soir comment t'as fait il a fait 40
minutes de quatre tirs sans que je les
ai pas vues passer à 2 minutes 22
minutes 28 derniers mois j'ai
l'impression que ça fait dix minutes
dont jean-luc vraiment il est
exceptionnel on les aime c'est vraiment
la famille et ce qui fait toutes les
semaines dans les quatre tiers je pense
que c'est une des meilleures chroniques
de la télévision de l'histoire tout le
monde m'en parle et jean-luc merci pour
tout
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur
chan
[Applaudissements]
vraiment je dis pas ça je dis pas ça
parce que c'est mon pote depuis 25 ans
mais jean-luc il a fait une année
exceptionnelle et guest managed a encore
cartonné hier soir gace faé a cartonné
dans tpm p il a fait un carton cette
année et les cafetières formidable donc
merci mon jean luc et tu sais qu'on
t'aime très fort et voilà donc bien
c'est jean luc et surtout bah oui